okay cool welcome so thanks for coming
all so as was said so it's a sponsor
talk but I will try to not make it any
advertisement or something like that so
it's really more about uh we have open
sourced a machine learning library where
we're just looking for contributors
building a small community and this is
about right I don't want to sell you
anything or something like that
okay so let's get started I think
is it okay or okay good so then um
so maybe first of all uh so this if you
are looking for something like a new
deep learning method or something like
that so you might be a bit disappointed
so this is more like the traditional
classic uh shallow learning stuff but
there I hope that it's quite Advanced
and that it actually works and you can
use it for real world use cases so this
is the idea so it should be relatively
off the shelf in a sense that you just
install the library and you're ready to
go for many use cases so this is the
idea and as I said we are looking for a
contributors hoping to grow Community
around it so similar to the case like
the big XG boost right so it's no
boosting first of all you will see later
on what it is I will try to explain the
method and yeah if you have any
questions in between
so just ask interactively that's okay
okay
good so um
first of all what is it about so um I
will explain the name a little bit later
on
um but it's actually a family of machine
learning methods so as I said it's uh
the traditional machine learning like
you you know it from things like random
forests or whatever right so this kind
of thing
um it's off the shelf in a sense that as
I said it's hopefully ready to use it's
general purpose in a sense that you can
use it for many use cases
um
you will see when I talk a little bit
why we developed this method and so on
so that we actually developed it on a
specific use case but later on realized
that we could use it basically all over
the place for structure data so that
means
of course for things like unstructured
data like computer vision natural
language processing nowadays you would
of course use deep learning so it makes
no sense to talk about such message so
this is really mainly with the focus on
structured data where you would not
necessarily need a deep learning
approach and sometimes it's pretty hard
to build one right both in terms of the
data needs and in terms of
tuning the model and so on
and yeah it's supervised learning for
regression and classification as I said
it's from several cases we will look at
a few in the in the following so um it's
actually a method that is a mix of
different ideas so you couldn't just
describe it as something like this is a
decision tree or this is something like
a linear regression or so the closest
relative actually is a generalized
additive models for the ones of you who
don't know what it is so I will explain
it a little bit on the on the next slide
what is behind but in principle you can
think of it as
linear regression where you have a link
function that allows you to for example
do multiplicative regression as well and
you would not necessarily do it only
linearly but you allow specific terms in
between right so not like a times X1
plus b times X2 you basically allow the
X's to be something more advanced right
so like a quadratic thing or even in the
action term
okay so then the main difference to the
other methods like generalized additive
models or maybe even neural networks
is that instead of estimating parameters
like the coefficients that I just
mentioned or maybe the weights in a
neural network which is basically the
same thing right it's also just many
linear models just stacked together so
instead of having such a parameterized
method in the first place here you
actually estimate factors for bin
features so that means for each of your
input variables like the different axes
you basically bin them you will see in a
second how this works so let's say 10
bins right so then you have 10 different
categories for each of the features and
for each of those bins you learn a
factor what is actually contributed to
the final result in the prediction or
adherence and those factors are
estimated so in a sense it is feels a
little bit like a
non-parameterized method but I hopefully
you will understand when I show you the
formula it's actually pretty
straightforward okay but in that sense
it offers you also a kind of individual
explainability so this was one of the of
the main motivation patients as well in
the beginning
and yeah today I will only show you a
pretty simplified version of of the
algorithm so that you can understand the
basic workings if you want to know all
the nitty-gritty details so we have
actually two papers that are on archive
then you can read through it if you want
okay but as I said so the main thing
today
um of course I want to explain you how
it works but the main thing is actually
that um
we decided after quite some time when we
used this so it's not a new method we
developed it actually several years ago
already we decided that we would want to
open sources as well so we used it
internally for many years for different
use cases but now we thought it might be
a good time to also not only publish the
methods how they work but also publish
the code right that means we have
something like a scikit-learn like usage
of this Library it is on GitHub it's
also easy to install just pip install
cycle boosting and there's also a
documentation that admittedly is not
super extended yet but hopefully one can
more or less understand how you would
use it and how it works and we are
working on it to make it better of
course
okay so now um I come to the different
modes so as I said you can use it for
several cases so this might look like uh
now a little bit uh difficult and
difficult to understand but hopefully
it's not that much so when we look at
those two so basically look at this one
here right so we talk here about
regression so that means your target is
a real valued number so for example the
famous price of a house or something
like I will later on talk a little bit
about demand forecasting so basically
when you want to predict uh the sales on
a given day for some article in a
supermarket or something like that right
so this is a regression and um sometimes
you have it like your target range is
minus and positive it can be anything so
then in such in such a case your model
usually would be something like a
gaussian right so this is what you
typically do so um
but if your target is only positive so
then usually your model is also
something else so then often a processor
distribution or a negative binomial
distribution which is something like a
gamma poisson if you want your password
distribution where the mean parameter is
itself comma distributed so something
like this is better suited and um so in
in a sense in from if you think on a
generalized additive or generalized
linear models this basically is the
typical linear regression case and this
one here would be plus our regression so
you basically have a Target where you
have a link function that is the
logarithm that basically brings you then
from the additive to the uh to the order
the inverse link brings you from the
additive to the multiplicative space and
then you have also multiplicative
effects and you have this target range
right so this is the view from a
generalized linear model perspective
and yeah so there are several different
other modes you could easily do this
with classification as well so there are
logistic regression for example you have
to lock it as link function is the same
game right so there your model would be
something like a Bernoulli distribution
so I will come later on to the models
again and to the other modes I will
describe briefly in the end so they are
not too important to understand the
thing it's always the same thing right
you have a link function you have a
target range and this decides about the
model topology if you want
okay so um the use case that I want to
describe a little bit uh because this
was actually where we developed it
historically as demand forecasting so
there the typical issue with which we
which we faced uh was that we have a
supermarket with many products right so
like many thousand products many stores
and we basically have hourly or daily
aggregated sales that we want to predict
so that means you have many individual
time series that you want to forecast
and something like that might look like
this one here right so you have a Time
series and you have the aggregated sales
over a day for example for even product
location combination in this uh this
case here it's aggregated on product
groups just for visualization or
something like that okay and sometimes
you see there are large Peaks so they
might be due to price reductions or so
if something is in promotion and usually
you see something like a weekly
structure so the typical thing with time
series right so and um on such a thing
um usually what you do is you go with
traditional Universe time series
forecasting first things like arima or
maybe even Facebook's profit or
something like that right so um and um
the advantage of using machine learning
over that first of all is that if you
learn an all-time series together you
can actually make use of the
commonalities between them and by doing
so you can reduce the variance so that
means Maybe
all products in a given group behave the
same thing right so they have the same
weekly structure or something like that
if you learn it on that level it's much
better than if you learn it individually
for each of the time series right so
this is something like the hierarchical
sense of it and the other thing is that
uh of course there you can easily
include such things like promotions as
external variables such as features in
the model so this is not that
straightforward if you have a typical
time series forecasting thing so this is
uh what we had and then there were a few
subtleties to it so we started actually
with something like a neural network
approach back then which is of course
also machine learning and does all these
things but we faced a few issues like
for example here you have categorical
features of very high cardinality so as
I mentioned products and locations right
so these are basically IDs if you want
in the first place of course you can do
something like embeddings and so on if
you go more advanced but in principle
these are IDs and you have many of them
right and to learn them one hard and and
so on is super hard that means you need
the method that can take care of that
you have actually mainly multiplicative
effects so like uh that the effect of or
the correlation between the feature and
the target is not additive in a sense
but it's multiplicative so that if you
double it the target is also double
something like that right
um and the demand is following typically
across our distribution as I mentioned
and um with all these things taking into
account we try to develop a method that
fulfills that and use the view of our
old findings from the previous methods
that actually came up with something new
in a relatively ad hoc sense first and
later on WE formalized it a little bit
to fit into that structure of a
generalized additive model so first of
all here look at the prediction view so
this is what I already mentioned now in
a simple formula so how it actually
looks for the multiplicative regression
mode as I mentioned so so here as I said
there is a very variation is
proportional to the level this would be
a multiplicative model this is what I
just told you and how the model looks
like
um I already said so we have the spins
of the features right so we have here
the different features so let's say 10
features uh that uh that we have so this
is running from one to ten so to say and
each of the features makes the
contribution uh to the final prediction
so let's say 0.8 1.2 times 2.5 something
like that right and I already set each
of the features comes with a number of
bins so let's say 10 bins or 100 bins or
all the different categories that you
have so like your thousand different
products or so and each of them got gets
a bin right and in for all of these bins
there is a factor I learned and if you
do a prediction you're one sample for
each of the features false also falls
only into one bin right you look it up
and you do now the prediction for
product number five and this is of
course only the prediction for this one
being all the other pins for the other
products don't care right so that means
to do a lookup if you want
for each of the features look into which
bin your sample Falls and then you can
easily multiply them up right if you
have beforehandler and the factors so
this is what I said in a sense this is
kind of a non-parametric because here
you have learned factors and not
parameters that are multiplied now with
the with the feature value itself you
just for the feature well you look up
into which bin you fall okay
so this is kind of the the strategy and
of course you have something like a
global Target average which gives you
the overall range and if you do so then
the neutral Factor would be one and each
time you see a deviation for from one
you see how much this feature
contributed and this is kind of the idea
of the individual explainability so
let's say you have three feature as I
said one is is one one is 0.8 one is 3.5
right so then this 3.5 is what drives
the prediction up for this one sample
compared to the average
so in that sense um you have this
intrinsic individual explainability
already in so you should not
um
confuse this with uh with a causal
effect of course because this is just
what the model means right so this is no
causal assumption about the structure of
the data generation process or so it's
really just what the model has learned
about the training data right in that
sense
um and yeah as I already said um
it's a machine learning method so we do
the typical machine learning IID
assumption so basically the independence
between the different samples and we
treat here each time step a sample so
that means our our thing is not only
product location which is one row but
basically also the date itself if you
want right so think of a spreadsheet for
each product location date combination
this would be like the key this is one
sample and we don't have a sequence a
sequence model here like a Transformer
or an RNN where we basically treat uh
all that all the the different time step
of one time series together in one
sample right we have one sample for each
of the time steps so that means we don't
make use of autocorrelation itself in a
sense you would have to bring this in
again via
something like an exponential weighted
moving average feature if you want if
you really want something like
autocorrelation to be to be treated in
writing a Transformer it's a similar
thing so they do it via the positional
encoding to bring this information in
because you have the permutation
invariance so okay forget it
okay so now to the uh to the training uh
to the training example so this is kind
of the one formula that I said so how
this thing works
um so it's actually a coordinate descent
method so that means it's not uh the
typical gradient descent where you look
at all the different parameters together
in the high dimensional space and you go
to the uh to the inverse hill climbing
thing right so here you basically treat
each of the dimensions separately one
after the other so in a sense that means
you start with all factors to one in a
global average and then you cyclically
uh iterate through the features so that
means you look first at the first
feature then look at the second feature
and so on and for each of the features
in each of the bins so a feature and the
different bins so let's say feature
number one and now we look at the fifth
pin for example we first of all sum up
all the target values that fall into
that bin and then we sum up all the
predictions and I come to that in a
second in the beginning this is just one
right so it's as simple as that sum them
up and you get the factor and the point
is now you always when you calculate
these predictions you just spare out the
feature that you are looking at at the
moment right so and then it is
non-aggregated view that I show you here
you basically always in each of the
iterations for each of the features you
calculated and you but it's a pretty
simple algorithm it just goes through
the features set all of them to the
factors that you have already learned in
the last iteration and just calculate
now the new one new right and you get
the feature you get the factor for this
pin out and this you do for all the
features in uh in several iterations
According to some some stopping criteria
in the end as always and you get
something like a loss out here if you
want so over the different iterations
and this is the procedure right it's in
principle
on a high level you can think of it as
as three Loops kind of thing so the
typical iterative thing where you go
over the iterations then you have ghosts
eventually coordinate descent light over
the features and in the end you have for
each of the of each of the bins you do
this in parallel right the bins are not
correlated to each other this is how the
method works so pretty simple right so
there are lots of subtleties as I said
so for example you could do this with a
learn rate you could do this in a sense
that you basically
uh take the the values from the last
iteration in and do a boosting like
update whatever right but in principle
the idea is exactly like that
okay now a few uh a few details uh
because binning is that important I just
want to show you how this works in
principle so for pinning for the
categorical features I already mentioned
it's pretty straightforward we just look
for example for the product IDs for each
of the products independently and we
just learn the factors here so that
means the red dots that you see here are
just the factors that I learned and I
show here in the end the truth in each
of the pins and the prediction in each
of the bins so that means the smoothed
factors is what the model has learned
right these are the factors in the model
and the predictions and the truths is
actually when you just look at this pin
and just do the the sums that I showed
you and divide it via the global average
so I will come in a second why they
don't are the same for all of the for
all of the cases so um yeah info
continuous features actually you do the
the beginning before all right so either
after the same bin width like with a
typical Equity distance binning or what
makes more sense in most of the cases
you have Equity statistics spinning so
that you just look that for each of the
each of the bins you have approximately
the same number of observations in and
you just vary to begin with so that you
can get there right so and then um this
is what you what comes out there
so in this kind of of optimization
scheme enables if you want in a sense a
local optimization in each bin because
as I said you look at all of the bins in
the feature and in each of the bins you
do an optimization so this is different
to what for example linear regression
would be doing so there you are fitting
one parameter to get the full feature
right and we do actually a fit if you
want in each of the bins so which is of
course giving a much lower bias in the
end
and you can also do things like
interaction terms as I mentioned
so you could easily do a pinning in two
Dimensions right so this would be that
so for example locations and products we
just do the binning in two dimensions
and for each of the product location
combinations you learn a factor same
thing right if you want this would be an
interaction term in a generalized
additive model so and with doing that
you can learn even more rare effects of
course and you can do this higher
dimensional as well so you can go
three-dimensional for a dimensional
depends on the on the data you have
right if you have enough data you can go
a pretty pretty complicated here get a
very complicated model but this then
also means that you are collecting
variants in a sense of course if you
want you can see this as kind of the
uh the depth in a decision tree right so
if you go for example in a decision tree
uh five uh five levels down right this
would be something like on a high level
similar to having an interaction term of
five here right that means usually you
come you come quite far with two or
three-dimensional effects and if you
want you can also enable partly a
hierarchical structure if you learn here
interaction effects for example with
product groups or with locations so like
a promotion for us given a location or
holiday effect for a given location or
something like that or product group if
you want
the second thing um is once you have
learned this factors afterwards you can
do something like as moving over it so
that means here this would be kind of
the factors that you would have learned
for different bins so let's say after
the first iteration and then you can
just move the functions like your
article polynomial or something through
it and then take the values that come
out of the smoothing as kind of the
values that you use for the next
iteration this makes sense because this
reduces just the variance because most
of the stuff is fluctuations so if you
know that they should make some sense in
the different bins right they should be
connected you can do something like that
and if you want you can also include
prior knowledge via that if you know
that the feature is monotonic or if you
want something to describe over the time
of the year so like a seasonality or
something like that you can easily
include it by describing these smoothing
terms if you want
okay and then um
the Bloods that I've showed you these
are kind of the analysis plots of uh of
this method if you want so they come out
of the training itself so basically
because these factors are what is
calculated in this visualization then
comes for free so they can actually help
a lot in the model development if you
want so it really helps if you want to
find out how different features are
correlated to the Target and so on and
they actually automatically generated
and here's what I said before so you
would see that the the red line here
would be the the smooth factors so like
the factors that the model has learned
and they might be different to the
actual truths or predictions in the end
the reason is that you have correlations
to other features as well right so then
you don't see them in the in the
marginal view but of course they are
reflected in the predictions itself so
it's kind of difficult to understand in
the beginning why there is this
difference and actually deviations of
the model so real biases you would see
that the predictions are not uh directly
with the target if you look in the
learning after the last iteration
okay so then real brief at the
characteristic I already said from the
topology it's similar to channelized
additive model the optimization itself
is a coordinate descent no credit
descent you have something like a
prerequisite that you be in the feature
which is not typical in most of the
cases and there are lots of
regularization methods that I have not
shown you so for example we're using a
conjugate priors for the features and so
on to do another uh regularization on
top of the smoothing
and if you want there are similarities
as I said from the model we already said
it so then if you want coordinate
descent dissimilar to backfitting and
generalized additive models but also to
forward stage wise modeling and boosting
the pinning is kind of similar to what
is done in live CBM so there they also
do something like pinning for very
similar reasons also for speed up so
that means it's kind of a mix of
different methods right I already said
it's um in a sense of the Shelf method
because it's a pretty simple algorithm
as you have seen it is robust and super
fast because it's that simple right you
have really few hyper parameters to tune
you don't have to do much data
pre-processing like for neural networks
also you can basically throw anything in
it's easily configurable for different
data types like continuous ones
categorical ones as I've shown you
missing values are supported I have not
talked a lot about that but it's just
one other bin right just a different
category
um you get this analysis plots that help
you you can easily make it more complex
if you want by including many
interaction terms so far you have to
give them by hand so we plan in the
future that we do something like an uh a
mode where we would help you like these
are the most important interaction terms
right so so far you have to basically
provide them from the outside and as I
said you can do multiplicative additive
regression you can also do
classification and also the other modes
that I have to skip now you get the
slides right so like for the rift
prediction where you get out the full
probability distribution rather than the
pure conditional mean so this is
important for a case like automated
replenishment as I said I dropped that
and also the elasticity prediction I
will drop so this is something like yet
another mode if you think about
generalized Adidas models the artist
things about scale and shape as well so
um this is yet another application that
we had for example for dynamic pricing
okay by that I'm done
um maybe in the end if you want you can
try it so we have actually set up a
hackathon where it would be great if a
few of you would uh would actually play
around with it this is actually for this
case that I mentioned like retail demand
forecasting so try to beat it
um I have implemented a
a simpler and a pretty Advanced cyclic
boosting model would be cool if somebody
can beat it either with cyclic boosting
or anything else right it's super hard
to beat it on that use case I think even
with a Transformer that I would be great
if somebody does okay thank you
[Applause]
thank you for your great presentation we
have some questions on slido if you have
any more questions you can just write it
down for room b09 and the first question
is what effect does The binning Have and
an independent variable is numeric when
the value is on the edge of a bin a
small increase can have a big effect
um yeah that's true so if you have a
continuous feature at some point you
have to decide about the bin widths of
course right so and it can be that if
you go from one pin to the next and
there's kind of a a gap between the
factors learned but usually you do the
smoothing afterwards that I've shown you
right and if you do something like
author polynomial or whatever a
piecewise linear thing also so you would
usually not see a big difference because
these are the factors that are actually
used later on so usually you see a
rather smooth thing from one bin to the
next if you would not do smoothing it's
correct then it can have a large effect
in worst case
next question is since it Loops over the
features that the order of the feature
matter that's good it's a good question
yes uh it the order of the features
matter if you don't want the order of
the features to matter you can easily
just include a learn rate so then it
would not matter anymore so if you
basically do only small steps like a
shrinkage method so then um it would not
really matter but if sometimes you want
to order to matter right if you know
what you are doing you can actually use
the order to actually include something
like a hierarchy or even a sense of
causality right so that means the order
can be helpful if you don't want it you
just choose to learn right
next question is does it scale well with
lots of feature and or bin size
for the pins it's really no problem as I
said so you can go as large as you want
it just learns a different an additional
parameter of course if you go to many
bins it means that you go low bias and
this also means that in worst case you
can overfit especially for categorical
features where you don't do this
smoothing so I can only do kind of the
Bayesian updates
for features in principle it doesn't
matter really because you treat them
sequentially right the runtime of course
gets longer because it's eventually but
it scales it just takes longer to train
but the training is super fast because
the method is so simple with the sums
the next question is how computationally
expensive is the deployment of this
model it's actually
um I would say super cheap compared to
most of the other methods again because
the algorithm is pretty simple and you
can't read the features sequentially
um I would say in principle there are
not many low bias methods like this that
are cheaper at least none that I would
really know of so from that sense I
think it's computationally really very
cheap what we don't have currently and
would but what would be easily to be
developed maybe something else for the
future is to completely parallelized
mode so at the moment we run this on one
note so to say but you could easily
paralyze with things like the ask or
whatever right so it is possible but at
the moment this is not the case
last question is
if you have to name a couple of
drawbacks of this method what will it be
um yeah I think the the biggest drawback
of course if you compare it to uh to
deep learning methods is that there is
no sense of deaths right so that means
um
uh to learn something like like what the
CNN is doing right so that you learn
typical hierarchical effects of the
representation or something like that
this you cannot do with a shallow method
but this is not only true for this one
but for any method but this would be
compared to uh to deep Nets compared to
things like ready and boosting and so on
I think the biggest drawback would be
that at least currently you have to
Define yourself uh what are the
interaction terms right this comes for
free in a tree based approach this can
be an advantage and a disadvantage but
if you want to be hands off right this
is kind of a disadvantage because you
don't get this right away but maybe one
could build something like that would be
great if somebody does
again thank you for the great
presentation and for answering all these
questions thank you